[Music]
sports health and community champion
caroline bailey caroline bailey started
a ladies walking group by inviting via
facebook like-minded ladies to join her
for a variety of short daily walks the
aim was to get people outdoors for
exercise fresh air and importantly to
make friends caroline puts together
walks for the week ahead and post them
on their groove facebook page arranging
meeting points and walk routes
throughout the district
there are several core walkers who
regularly attend some suffering with
health issues caroline makes everyone
feel welcome tailoring walk so that
there are no steep inclines to conquer
and ensuring that everyone enjoys the
fresh air with a sense of achievement
and fun the walking group is now
branched out and set up a book club
where they meet at each other's house
once a month and review a book which has
been nominated the previous month this
again has brought a small community of
people together improving health along
the way don't more classic volunteers
over 300 volunteers give up their time
to support the dark more classic weekend
to make the event the national success
it has become whether standing is
marshal for up to ten hours in all
weather conditions directing traffic and
cyclists volunteering in the event
village over the weekend or in the many
hours spent preparing up to the weekend
event itself is well-known that is the
volunteers that make the event with the
smiles cheers and celebrations including
the cheering of every rider over the
finish line this year the team was put
to the test delivering the event in the
worst conditions but everyone went above
and beyond to ensure riders were safe
and had a great experience
the dartmoor Classic would not be able
to host such a nationally recognized
event attracting thousands of extra
visitors to South Devon without the
amazing volunteers
Rex Meredith Rex is a 75 year old
energetic participant in the local
community Rex has been a major
contributor to the promotion of
castellón rowers and is keen to make
rowing open to people of all ages and
abilities as the sole remaining founder
member of castellón rowers Rex has
actively led its growth and development
and a second boat was purchased six
months ago to satisfy the increasing
demand of people wanting to row with the
group that has over 65 registered
members alongside this Rex has been a
regular supporter of the River teen
rowing club providing safety boat cover
without wrecks at the popular and well
attended rowing events they simply would
not be able to run safely his efforts
have enabled the club to introduce
rowing to over 180 novices this year and
to continue to offer support to the 20
plus junior developing rowers
[Music]
you